[Música]
ah
para ir conociéndonos un poco me
gustaría mostrarles algo de lo que he
estado haciendo estos últimos meses
[Música]
ah
tal
[Música]
y
mi primera aproximación con la
fotografía
fue como creo que nos ha pasado a casi
todos buscando documentar registrar
lugares momentos situaciones personas
pero me daba cuenta con el transcurrir
del tiempo que mis fotos siempre
necesitaban un complemento necesitaban
el complemento de la palabra hablada
escrita
pero la foto sola no alcanzaba a
transmitir lo que yo quería lo que había
sentido o lo que pretendía que el otro
sintiese al mirarla que era lo que me
pasaba cuando veía fotos en revistas en
libros en aquel momento no tengo existía
internet de fotógrafos a los que yo
admiraba veía sus fotos y mi sensación
era de haber estado al lado de ellos
cuando la estaban haciendo
de haber sentido el mismo frío de haber
sentido la misma emoción y mis fotos no
tenían eso
entonces
en ese camino me puse a estudiar dije
acá falta algo
empecé a investigar a indagar un poco me
puse a estudiar me puse a estudiar el
manejo de la luz del color del foco
digamos todos los aspectos técnicos que
me podían llegar a ayudar en eso
y mis fotos iban mejorando de a poco
pero no alcanzaba
entonces seguí estudiando y empecé a
prestar más atención a esas fotos de
esos fotógrafos que lograban emocionarme
y transmitir me cosas
y seguir con los pintores también me
pasaba con determinados pintores con
determinadas obras que yo sentía que me
emocionaban que hacían mi vida un
poquito mejor por el solo hecho de estar
disfrutando las que era lo que yo quería
hacer con mis fotos
y estaba en ese camino cuando empiezo a
ver que algunas de mis fotos iban
logrando de a poco eso que yo quería que
la gente que las veía empezaba a tener
una respuesta emocional similar a lo que
yo había buscado que me iban diciendo
si siento como si hubiera estado ahí
alguna persona que nunca había conocido
el lugar o yo estuve ahí y sentí la
misma sensación que tuve en aquel
momento entonces eso me ayudó a darme
cuenta que estaba yendo por un buen
camino
y un día me animé muchas con más
experiencia a cuestas y con más de estas
situaciones vividas
me animé e hice mi primera muestra
individual primera de casi 30 que van
ahora y ahora van a ver por qué tantas
cuando hice esa primera muestra que
fueron casi 30 obras mías y que fue
realmente un gran paso adelante el
animarse a exponerse frente a la gente
la respuesta fue fabulosa es decir la
emoción o la felicidad que yo sentía al
ver la interacción que la gente tenía
con mis fotos y ese ida y vuelta y que
yo me daba cuenta o sentía que los
estaba les estaba haciendo su vida un
poco mejor
compartiendo les estas fotos eso me
llevó a entrar en un camino del que ya
sabía que nunca más iba a salir a un
camino no solo de compartir mi obra sino
fundamentalmente de estar buscando todo
el tiempo ver cómo hago para que mis
fotos transmitan cada vez más y más y
más esas emociones que yo quiero que
transmitan
y estaba en ese camino de esa búsqueda
cuando empiezo a darme cuenta que había
muchas de las imágenes que yo tenía en
mi cabeza que quería plasmar en una foto
que era muy difícil que lo lograra si no
tenía una planificación previa es decir
la cosa no era tan me di cuenta que la
cosa no era tan como había pensado al
principio
de que era ir por él por la vida o ir
por el camino con técnica encima y
simplemente reconociendo situaciones
sino que había muchas que las tenía que
ir a buscar y para ir a buscarlas tenía
que estar preparado y estar preparado
significaba no solo estar preparado en
lo técnico sino estar preparado en lo
logístico en el operativo en saber en
qué momento del año podía conseguir
determinada foto qué temperatura iba a
ver a qué hora en función de esa
temperatura cómo tenía que estar
preparado qué equipo tenía que llevar
para que cuando llegara solo quedará
hacer la foto si la naturaleza
acompañaba que por suerte no siempre
acompaña si no sería todo demasiado
fácil y aburrido
y así en ese camino fueron apareciendo
la vía láctea sobre el cono de ahorita
en salta auroras boreales en la laguna
yo pulsarlo en islandia
giro de estrellas a la medianoche en el
campo de piedra pómez en catamarca o un
amanecer en monument valley todas fotos
que había tenido en mi cabeza porque
hallamos toda esta planificación nace de
una visión previa ya no es que es
simplemente planificar por la nada hay
una previsualización previa una
formación en la imagen la mente del
fotógrafo de una imagen que quiere
materializar y después viene esa
planificación para hacerlo
y un día también reflexionando sobre
estoy buscando siempre
que las fotos fueran mejores y contarán
más las historias que yo quería
empecé a reflexionar que quizás
si bien tener un plan era esencial
quizás había oportunidades que estaban
pasando alrededor mío y me las estaba
perdiendo por seguir tan estrictamente
ese plan
y hubo algunos hechos que me fueron
marcando eso que en realidad fue un
camino un poco paralelo con ese que les
conté recién de la planificación un día
por ejemplo estaba en
el calafate había estado haciendo fotos
del glaciar perito moreno sea caminando
sobre el glaciar toda la tarde haciendo
fotos hayamos estado con la familia
cuando volvemos del glaciar llegamos al
hotel
me había nos habíamos sentado a tomar un
café para reponernos un poco del
esfuerzo del día
y veo que se empieza a poner el sol y
aparecen nubes lenticulares que son las
típicas nubes patagónicas
que empezaban a aparecer teñidas por ese
sol naranja que se estaba por esa luz
naranja del sol que se estaba poniendo
inmediatamente dejé todo lo que estaba
haciendo agarré la cámara trípode y salí
corriendo hacia una playa cercana para
tratar de hacer mi foto ya tenía la foto
en la cabeza ya cuando vi eso se azuza
sabía que quería atrás mío salió a mi
familia vamos siempre juntos en la
mayoría de las fotos que han visto de
los viajes siempre han estado alrededor
y cuando estaba llegando a la playa
aparece estamos ya iba visualizando
había una colina con las nubes
lenticulares que bajaban ahí estaba todo
perfecto solo tenía que llegar a un
lugar para hacerla desde ahí y cuando
estaba llegando a ese lugar veo una
persona que aparece caminando en esa
colina y si ustedes prestaron atención a
esas primeras fotos mías que pasaron de
lo que hice últimamente no hay personas
y no es casualidad que no haya personas
no hay personas porque es lo que yo
busco es son paisajes naturales sin
intervención humana pero en ese momento
mi primera reacción fue esta persona me
arruinó la foto
el plan que yo tenía desapareció en el
mismo momento que la apareció caminando
resultado después por la pose que adopto
resultó ser otro fotógrafo como yo que
estaría en la misma
la cuestión que después de esa primera
reacción la segunda por suerte fue hacer
la foto ahí hay algo que hice esta foto
y en esa foto claramente si esa persona
no estuviera ahí la foto sería
completamente distinta es decir el hecho
de que esa persona está ahí no sólo le
da escala
a la situación por la referencia humana
sino sobre todo le agrega dramatismo y
potencia
otra vez
estaba en el golfo nuevo frente a puerto
madryn fotografiando delfines mi plan
había sido ir a fotografiar delfines
había estudiado un montón sobre el tema
iba con todo el equipo adecuado para eso
la hora del día la época del año todo de
acuerdo a lo previsto
encima nos había tocado un día fabuloso
para los que conocen madryn y esa zona
saben que este mar no es muy común
normalmente hay mucho viento y el mar es
mucho más picado en esta situación sin
viento y sin nublado es el ideal de un
fotógrafo estaba haciendo estas fotos de
delfines cuando de repente estaba
concentrado en los delfines que estaban
cerca del bote de repente empiezan a
saltar delfines que estaban muy lejos 50
60 metros yo saco el lente que tenía que
era el que me permitía tener ese ángulo
de visión tan amplio y pongo otro lente
que era el que me iba a dar un ángulo de
visión estrecho para poder llegar a esos
delfines termino de hacerlo y esos
delfines que estaban lejos no siguieron
saltando y empieza a saltar uno que
estaba a seis o siete metros primera
reacción ley de murphy que no
hay veces que no se cumpla
por suerte otra vez en forma casi primal
o instintiva algo me dijo ahí hay una
oportunidad aprovecharla
le hice esta foto el salto donde el fin
austral no era lo que yo buscaba yo lo
que buscaba era mi foto del delfín
entero saltando lo que había planificado
claramente estas fotos infinitamente
mejor que lo que yo había planificado
entonces bueno estas situaciones que se
iban repitiendo
me llevaron a indagar un poco más sobre
esto que me había pasado
y en esa indagación me di cuenta que lo
que me estaba pasando tenía un nombre
serendipia
qué es la serendipia el hallazgo
afortunado de algo distinto a lo que
estamos buscando pero que termina siendo
mejor o más interesante o más importante
que eso que buscábamos digamos y es el
hallazgo y el darnos cuenta de que eso
es más importante ya dije si esto tiene
un nombre es evidente que no es algo que
me está pasando a mí solo es algo que le
pasa a mucha gente
enseguida enseguida pero dentro de ese
camino dije ah si yo quiero mejorar mis
fotos
y no quiero desaprovechar oportunidades
evidentemente lo que tengo que hacer es
buscar permanentemente un equilibrio
entre esa planificación y la serendipia
es decir siempre tener un plan nunca
andar para donde me lleve el viento solo
porque si siempre tener un plan con un
objetivo
pero a su vez
estar siempre lo suficientemente
flexible alerta y sensible a lo que pasa
alrededor para poder pegar el salto de
ese plan salirme de ese plan para
aprovechar cualquier oportunidad que
viene por afuera y que reconozca como
tal
y digo bueno eso que me lo planteé desde
la fotografía
cuando lo empecé a pensar un poco más
dije pucha esto no es solo fotografía si
lo aplico a cualquier otro ámbito de mi
vida es tan valedero como en la
fotografía
me gustaría mostrarles el resultado en
lo personal de esta búsqueda del
equilibrio entre la planificación y la
serendipia
[Música]
i
yo
y
[Música]
arte no es lo que vemos sino lo que
hacemos ver a los demás
edgard degas
[Música]
ah
no fotografía es como se ve la
fotografía cómo se siente david alan
harvey
[Música]
entonces
aquí
[Música]
ah
ver no es suficiente para fotografiar
hay que sentir andrew cartes
[Música]
no
ah
y más
[Música]
para
para terminar para terminar les planteo
un breve ejercicio durante 10 segundos
pensemos cada uno cuál fue la última vez
que aprovechó una oportunidad a partir
de un plan y la última vez que aprovechó
una oportunidad a partir de la
serendipia 10 segundos
si alguna de las respuestas a algunas de
las preguntas quedo sin respuesta o fue
difícil encontrar es muy probable que
haya oportunidades que están pasando a
nuestro alrededor y las estemos dejando
pasar muchas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]